die player wann ist der neue film von
steven spielberg das ist ein film der
spiel in 25 jahren in einer welt in der
sitzung soziale medien und ein einziges
gigantisches spiel das große refugium
für alle leute geworden sind weil die
soziale wirkliche welt dermaßen die
hölle gerutscht ist dass es da einfach
kein spaß mit 2045 kann man nirgends
mehr hätten es deswegen genau der
richtige für dieses buch denn es ist ein
buch von eines kleinen dass er verfilmt
wird weil er auch drin vorkommt nämlich
als eines von tausenden von sachen die
aus den 80ern und aus dem letzten
jahrhundert stammen was nämlich so eine
nostalgie welt ist die die leute in 25
jahren offen weise lieben im spiel wie
in der wirklichkeit wie peter parker
oder aber er starb als ich klein war
meine mama und das interessante ist
dadurch hat er die möglichkeit als
derzeit kritiker spielberg der filme wie
schön dass liste münchen lincoln gemacht
hat er also sozusagen sich mit der
menschlichen zivilisation und history
beschäftigt hat sich mit den
hinterlassenschaften des popcorn
künstler spielberg der jurassic park
gemacht hat
gemacht hat usw quasi auf eigene
augenhöhe auseinanderzusetzen
[Musik]
im grunde geht durch den spielberg so
eine art riss durch so eine art mauer
durch zwischen dem ernst spielberg und
dem spa spielberg und was man an dem
film jetzt aber sieht ist das in dem
spaß spielberg eine menge ernst schon
immer drin war und in dem ernst
spielberg unter umständen menge spaß
drin sein kann und holen das jetzt
auseinander raus die beiden zwillinge
die leute kommen die oasis weil sie da
alles machen können
und sie bleiben weil sie da alles sein
können spürst du das
ja nur hier habe ich das gefühl dass ich
was nährt aber ich würde sagen leute die
schon immer ein computerspiel
interessant fanden finden den film
interessant weil er sich auf neujahr
damit auseinandersetzt und heute den
computerspielen noch nie interessant
fanden finde es vielleicht hinterher
interessant durchschnitt mit uns die
ohren
[Applaus]
[Musik]